People often confuse food allergies
and food intolerances.
But it's important to know the difference
because they each require
a different treatment.
So what is the difference?
[Body Stuff with Dr. Jen Gunter]
A food allergy is your body's
immune system
responding to specific proteins
in certain foods.
For instance, in shellfish,
one of the triggers for allergic reactions
is a protein called tropomyosin.
And with peanuts, it can be a reaction
to one of its many proteins.
When a food particle enters the body
of someone who's allergic,
the body's immune system
perceives it as a problem, an invader.
Just as your body might respond
to a virus as a threat,
with food allergies,
part of your immune system
sees the protein of the food as a threat.
The allergic reaction can be thought of
as a disproportionate
and inappropriate response
from the immune system to the food.
Allergic reactions can range
from being mild:
tingles in the mouth, hives and rashes,
to being extremely severe,
like having trouble breathing.
And they can even be life threatening.
Allergic reactions, with some exceptions,
almost always happen quickly,
within 30 minutes of eating
or exposure to the food.
A food intolerance, on the other hand,
is usually our body having trouble
digesting certain foods.
Unlike allergies, food intolerances
are not related to the immune system.
For instance, being lactose intolerant
means you don't have enough of the enzyme
that breaks down the lactose in dairy.
Intolerance to certain foods
can often result in digestive issues,
including bloating, diarrhea
or just generally feeling unwell.
Intolerance to food can happen
pretty quickly too,
but could also show up
in the next few days.
In other words,
if you experience unpleasantness
from something you've eaten a day before,
most of the time it's not an allergy.
There's a third kind of reaction
that's neither an allergy
or an intolerance.
For example, celiac disease
is an autoimmune condition
triggered by eating foods
containing gluten.
Celiac disease may share some similar
symptoms to a food intolerance,
such as bloating or belly pain.
But unlike celiac disease,
food intolerances don't damage
the small intestine.
So with all these real
but nuanced differences,
what's the best way
to get a proper diagnosis?
Don’t get one of those “do-it-yourself
at-home food-sensitivity” kits.
Those tests are not scientifically proven
to do what they purport to do,
and they aren't reliable diagnostic tools.
If you wonder whether you have
an allergy or an intolerance
or celiac disease,
talk to your doctor.
They'll be able to recommend
the right course of action.
And in the case of food allergies,
an allergist is your go-to person.
The two common ways
they'll be able to diagnose you
is by taking a really good food history
and giving you an oral food challenge
by giving you certain foods
and seeing what happens
in a medically safe
and controlled environment.
An allergist can also come up with a plan
in case you're exposed
to a food you're allergic to
and may even be able to recommend
treatments for some of those allergies.